on va commencer donc par marine le pen
et ses déclarations sur l'extension de
la pma à laquelle elles s'opposent au
nom de l'intérêt de l'enfant je vous
propose de l'écouter
nous sommes contre l'ouverture à tous le
monde entre guillemets de la faim
réaction médicalement assistée on ne
peut dire qu'un enfant tu es né d'un
homme et tu es né d'une femme faut il
faut tout le tribut si vous voulez à
dissimuler cette vérité biologique qui
est utile pour la construction
psychologique de l'enfant
je suis content alors on va pas refaire
le fond du débat c'est vraiment on
s'intéresse à la stratégie de marine le
pen elle avait dit qu'elle était contre
le barrage pour tous au moment de
l'adoption de la loi taubira
quand elle s'était présentée en 2010 est
elle avait même inscrit dans son
programme l'abrogation de la loi taubira
son remplacement par un pacs améliorée
mais en fait elle avait très peu fait
campagne sur ce thème elle n'en parlait
même pratiquement jamais s quel arrêt
décidé adria aujourd'hui de combler un
angle mort de son programme qui était
essentiellement consacrée à l'économie
et au social et au régaliens je suis pas
sûr je pense pas que ce enfin je ne suis
pas sûr que ce sera pas vraiment
significatif parce que comme vous l'avez
souligné
elle a toujours été très discrète voire
mal à l'aise sur ces sujets qui
pourraient elles sont plus de dix heures
de société qu autre chose et
je ne suis pas sûr que ce serait très
rationnel de le faire en fait parce que
quand on regarde les déterminants de
vote de la population de l'ensemble des
électeurs
il ya très peu d'électeurs qui se
déterminent sur ces sujets là donc voilà
les experts qui placent en tête de leurs
préoccupations
les sujets de 10 de sociétés sont quand
même une vraiment une petite partie d'un
côté ou de l'autre
donc je pense que l'intérêt quand on
aspire à gagner une élection sur ces
sujets là c'est de ne pas apparaître
trop radicale d'un côté ou de l'autre
donc je suis pas persuadé d'ailleurs
quand on regarde l'extrait quand on
entend parler elle n'est pas vraiment
radical non plus à la pas un discours
extrêmement conservateur parce que elle
parle de la filiation etc
mais on n'est pas encore d'une clarté
totale ya pas une doctrine élaborée donc
je ne suis pas sûr je pense que ça peut
être un petit effet d'opportunité avec
le score de belhani assez faible et
peut-être une volonté de aussi de
contrecarrer un petit peu marion
maréchal mais il faut attendre avant de
savoir si c'est une tournant
conservateur
oui est ce qu'il n'ya pas aussi je
m'adresse à fergane une façon de faire
oublier les lacunes de son programme
économique dont les ambiguïtés sont
apparus à tous tpt depuis qu'elle a
abandonné l'objectif de quitter l'union
européenne et de quitter l'euro est ce
qu a pas un malaise qu'elle veut qu'elle
veut masquer en s'intéressant à l'autre
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec votre
proposition enfin c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui mais le pen on le sait
son programme économique a été qualifié
de fantaisiste voilà par tous les
experts qui ont été récemment sur ces
questions aujourd'hui il me semble que
la valeur ajoutée d'une droite qui
aspire à former une grande coalition
puisque c'est aussi le sujet dominant et
l'ambition en tout cas de beaucoup
d'intellectuels de casser la frontière
entre le centre droit et l'extrême
droite
face à une droite qui en réalité a
toujours échoué à se mettre d'accord sur
une doctrine économique cohérente parce
qu'elle est handicapée par un héritage
gaulliste qui n'a jamais été très clair
sur ces questions
finalement les enjeux sociétaux les
enjeux dit culturel où les enjeux de
civilisation comme ces intellectuels les
appels et bien s'avèrent être les seuls
niche électorale idéologique sur
lesquels ils peuvent espérer un peu de
cohérence donc moi d'un point de vue
électoral effectivement ça ne m'étonne
pas
aujourd'hui marine le pen à bord de ces
sujets maintenant je doute effectivement
là je rejoins adrien que ça suffira à
fédérer beaucoup d'électeurs puisque
même si effectivement les sujets société
passionne les français ça reste quand
même des préoccupations qui sont qu'ils
sont mineurs contenu aujourd'hui des
problèmes que traverse la france
oui je vous voyais hocher la tête quand
adria parlait de l'électorat
conservateur est ce qu est ce que c'est
une position qui dispose de même s'il
n'est pas destiné à durer et à être un
des axes nouveaux axes de la stratégie
de marine le pen est ce que c'est une
position qui vise à séduire les
électeurs de françois vit bel ami oui
moi je pense que c'est plutôt ça qu'elle
cherche à faire elle avait été quand
même très absente sur la question de la
loi taubira en 2013
elle a des positions effectivement en
matière de bioéthique et de moeurs qui
sont quand même assez peu clair j'en
conviens parfaitement quand elle dit par
exemple que la question de l'avortement
c'est du chiqué ya hélas dans le fond
elle le prend une position qui est somme
toute assez assez modérée parce qu'elle
se prononce contre la pma pour tout pas
contre la pma tout court pour ma part je
suis hostile mais ça ne me regarde que
moi aussi la pma dans tous les cas parce
que il ya un tri d'embryons et que par
conséquent il y avait des questions et
des questions dit il a en revanche et
c'est très clair me semble-t-il
elle essaye de rattraper le retard
qu'elle avait pris en 2013 et que même
si elle avait maintenu dans son
programme en 2017
l'abrogation de la loi taubira elle
apparaissait comme étant peu crédible
sur ce sujet contrairement à d'autres si
elle est d'autant plus je dirais active
sur ce sujet me semble-t-il c'est que 1
il y à leur tour qui n'est pas vraiment
un retour mais cannes est quand même un
de marion maréchal qui évidemment sur
ces sujets là est plus crédible qu'elle
est qu'elle est plus à l'aise et donc
par conséquent et peut-être plus
convaincu bien sûr
et que donc évidemment elle essaye de
détendre son spectre peu son spectre
politique
et puis je crois qu'il ya une autre
chose une autre raison c'est que il peur
il pourrait y avoir d'une certaine
manière une convergence une convergence
des luttes à la pma pour les bobos et
puis les des remboursements de la
sécurité sociale pour les prolos donc
peut-être qu'effectivement elle
s'imagine que il pourrait y avoir une
rencontre de la la france conservatrice
elle mpt et puis des ligier gilet jaune
les pourrait renaître de leurs cendres
il est question précisément de
rembourser la pma étendu il n'est pas du
tout question de la déremboursés c'était
il ya des médicaments qui eux sont
déremboursés par ailleurs donc voilà
enfin c'est moi c'est pas le débat sur
la tête lui qui fit quand on raisonne en
termes de parts de marché électoral ce
qui n'a pas toujours un danger de perdre
d'un côté ce qu'on gagne de l'autre
appliqué au cas du rassemblement
national
est-ce que la stratégie qui était celle
de florian philippot on ne parle pas des
sujets de société
on parle fait dans le social on parle du
social on tient bon et de l'immigration
mais on tient sur le social un discours
que un autre frontiste nicolas bay avait
comparé au discours de la cgt avait
amené des électeurs avaient contribué au
succès du front national est ce que si
elle retourne vers un discours ou si
elle va vers un discours plus
conservateur don de filippo ne voulait
pas à ce que ces électeurs là ne risque
pas de s'en aller oui moi je pensais je
sais pas si vous aviez vu qu'il ya une
dizaine de jours emmanuelle mignon qui a
été la directrice à dire aux stands
occupés a dit yves maintenant quand on
est à droite il faut laisser faut
considérer que l'électorat de droite qui
sont figés la question des moeurs et
donc je pense que emmanuelle mignon qui
est une femme intelligente et assez
stratège quand elle dit ça l'avait fait
quand même le projet nicolas sarkozy en
2007 qui lui a permis de gagner qui a
trianguler je pense que c'est un très
bon indicateur
la deuxième chose c'est que lorsque
edouard philippe fait son discours est
applaudie par sa majorité soit disant
discours de gauche qui en fait place la
question sociétale à la place de la
question sociale vous avez raison il ya
une espèce d'incapacité à penser la
question sociale qu'ils hissent à la
fois du côté de la majorité et du côté
de son opposition
moi je pense que c'est quelque chose de
dangereux et que marine le pen sait que
c'est dangereux que la question sociale
on la remplace par la question sociétale
d'ailleurs la première réaction
elle a eu c'était de dire au fond je
suis pas sûr que la pma soit la question
qui préoccupe tous les français et moi
je trouve que c'était une réaction assez
je déteste marine le pen je tiens à le
dire mais je trouve c'était une réaction
politiquement très fine
parce que je pense qu'on ne peut pas
continuer à remplacer la question
sociale par des enjeux sociétaux alors
même qu on le sait les inégalités
s'accroissent
c'est un sujet de ghettoïsation des
territoires hélas ce que j'observe c'est
dans l'extrait discours que vous nous
avez passé elle est très mal à l'aise
lorsqu'il s'agit de parler le dit la pma
pour tout le monde alors que c'est la
pma pour toutes les femmes
donc on voit qu'elle connaît pas du tout
le sujet moi c'est ça qui me frappe ça
me rappelle un peu le deuxième tour le
camp le débat deuxième tour on voit que
sur certaines questions
elle est au fond très pataude et qu'elle
ferait mieux de ne pas s'en approcher je
pense que si elle est un peu c'est une
bonne stratège politique si elle le
comprend suffisamment vite elle laissera
sa marion maréchal-le pen
d'ailleurs on a posé la question à nos
internautes à mama marine le pen at-elle
raison de s'opposer à l'extension de la
pma aux couples de femmes
et eux répondent oui à 51% ce qu'une
petite majorité et non à 49% en gal nous
écrit la fille ciel est décidément bien
grosse pour récupérer les perdu des
républicains comme en croit cette
personne dont le seul objectif est de
récupérer des voix en activant les peurs
les haines et les progrès sont possibles
voilà et nous avons le fidèle babineau
qui nous peu importe les positions de
marine le pen le l'opinion publique est
majoritairement favorable à l'extension
de la pma il me semble que oui selon des
sondages et c'est vrai vous disiez tout
ce qu'on pouvait plus coller des
positions sur ce sujet avec des
appartenances politiques elle ne se
recoupent plus on a vu que à la
présidentielle l'électorat catholique
avait voté bâtiment plutôt pour le forez
venema qui comptent eux non mais ça ça
brouille les lignes